ein jugendlicher lernt im internet ein
mädchen kennen freut sich auf das erste
treffen doch der schüler aus der nähe
von minden läuft in eine mörderische
liebesfalle und überlebt das date nur
knapp ein teenager drama das heute vor
gericht in bielefeld endete
[Musik]
ich hoffe mir für heute einfach dass die
nro teil kriegen was auch gerecht ist zu
der sache nie gemacht haben und dass ich
endlich damit abschließen kann
rückblick es ist der 31 juli vergangenen
jahres max verabredet sich mit jesse
kennt das mädchen nur von instagram zum
treffen begleitet ihn sein freund luca
wir lernen gleich vielleicht ein paar
nette mädels kennen und dann mal gucken
rostocks war gibt dass er am ende des
tages um sein leben kämpfen muss arnd
max zu dem zeitpunkt noch nicht am
vereinbarten treffpunkt wartete nichts
eine internet-bekanntschaft jesse auf
ihn es ist ronja seine ex gemeinsam mit
ihrem neuen freund kai k und als wir
dort ankamen haben die mein kumpel auf
die nase gehauen dann haben die auf mich
eingestochen
im selben moment
hat mein kumpel noch gesagt scheiße wir
müssen hier weg die haben den messer max
wird opfer eines heimtückischen
mordversuchs die polizei ist sicher
richtig zweimal aufs ein 16 jähriges
opfer ein einstich trifft den schüler in
die schulter der zweite seitlich in den
oberkörper nur knapp an der
hauptschlagader vorbei obwohl er
lebensgefährlich verletzt ist können max
und sein freund fliehen der 16-jährige
wird operiert er überlebt wenige tage
später nehmen ermittler ronja und kalkar
feststellen beweismittel sicher doch bis
heute ist ihr motiv unklar im nachhinein
denke ich heute darüber das ist immer
noch nicht also ich kann es halt immer
noch nicht fassen dass das passiert ist
und dass das die das wagen mit ihr habe
ich ja zusammen eine beziehung geführt
und das war dann schon also das ist
unfassbar und unvorstellbar
ja da ist man angespannt
die hoffnung dass es kein mildes urteil
gibt definitiv aber letztendlich haben
dass die richter zu entscheiden
dann werden wir damit leben müssen so
wie immer